hello and welcome i'm james murphy and
today i'm going to show you why
every proof that you've seen of the fact
that 0.99 repeating equals 1
is wrong don't worry it is true this
isn't one of those videos
it's just the proofs that you've seen
that are wrong so first
i'll show you why those other proofs are
wrong and then i'll show you my
actual proof the vast majority of proofs
that .99 repeating equals one
are so-called algebraic proofs they
start with
some number they do some algebraic
manipulations and then they somehow
derive
that one is equal to 0.99 repeating from
that these are by far the most common
kind of proof that you'll see when you
look it up
and at first glance they look pretty
sensible i start with x
being 0.99 repeating then i multiply by
10
i subtract x and then i solve for x
equals 1.
seems valid right we all know a third is
0.33 repeating
multiply by 3 and then we get 1 is 0.99
repeating
right well it turns out there are
multiple mistakes in these proofs
well right at the very start we've
actually made a huge mistake
just by writing 0.99 repeating i'm
implicitly assuming that it exists if
.99 repeating
didn't exist then i wouldn't be able to
multiply it by 10 and then solve for it
this is the error that pretty much every
video makes i've only seen
one that doesn't make this mistake let
me show you what can go wrong
in a very similar situation by making
this assumption that it does exist
instead of looking at 0.99 repeating
let's look at a very similar expression
let's suppose that a number 9 repeating
and then the point exists so i'm
thinking here as
the decimal point with nines extending
out
on the left side of it instead of on the
right side of it i start with 9
repeating
i multiply by 10 i add 9 and i see that
i end up back
with the number that i started with so
then i can solve for that algebraically
and i get that x is minus 1. pause the
video and check the steps if you want
so do you believe that 9 repeating point
is equal to negative one well no you
really shouldn't
there are number systems where this kind
of thing is true
but the real numbers is not one of them
okay so suppose you're willing to
believe that it does exist
as a real number then the rest of the
proof works right
well still no so what's wrong is it one
of the highlighted green
statements which one of those is wrong
well none of them
all of those statements are true they're
true because .99 repeating is equal to
one
but these proofs don't show it you have
to keep in mind that a proof of
something is not
simply a list of true statements that
ends in the one that you're looking for
i can't just say one plus one equals two
two plus two equals four
the fundamental theorem of calculus
holds these are all true statements
but this is not a proof of the
fundamental theorem of calculus
you need to show why each step implies
the next
since the rules of algebra are so well
known
in algebraic proofs it's very common to
leave off this reasoning but for now let
me make those implications explicit
so in this slide i'm using this implies
arrow
to indicate that each line implies the
next line i claim that the issue with
these proofs
lies in these arrows not in the
statements themselves
these red arrows specifically look at
the first step on the left
i multiply 0.99 repeating by 10
and i end up with 9.99 repeating now
for ordinary finite decimal expansion
numbers
we know that multiplying by 10 is the
same as just
moving the decimal point one to the
right but how do we know that that holds
for repeated decimals
after all you could never finish the
computation of multiplying it out
now again this is true you are allowed
to do this
but we haven't justified y in this proof
the reason that you're allowed to is
actually a fact from calculus not
algebra
now while this step is fine if you're
familiar with calculus
it's essentially just pushing a constant
inside a limit
the general population that would be
interested in answering this question
is 0.99 repeating equal to 1 we can't
assume that they know that
if we just use that fact i think we're
kind of doing them a disservice because
it doesn't really answer their question
all we've really done is hidden the
details in another thing that they don't
understand
the problem with the red arrow on the
right is pretty similar
how do i know that multiplying .33
repeating
times three actually gives .99 repeating
and as long as we're on the topic of
hiding details in places you don't
understand
why are you so okay with one-third being
exactly equal to 0.33 repeating
that sounds kind of just as hard to
prove as 0.99 repeating is equal to 1.
people seem a lot more okay with that
one but i don't really think you should
be
okay let's start working towards an
actual proof first
let's address what i think is the real
source of your confusion
the definition of 0.99 repeating what
does
.99 repeating actually mean it is
definitely
not some kind of mystical number with
infinitely many nines after the decimal
point
that's not a definition you have to give
a definition in terms of things that are
already understood
so here's how we actually define 0.99
repeating
we start by defining a sequence the
first element of the sequence is 0.9
then 0.99 then 0.999
and so on where the nth term in the
sequence
is just point followed by n9
you can write it for an arbitrary n
using this capital sigma fancy math
notation
but that's not really necessary remember
that for a fixed value of n
this is just a finite decimal
approximation it has
n digits after the decimal point and it
stops the definition
of 0.99 repeating is just the number
that this sequence approaches
if there is such a number in
mathematical terms we say that it is the
limit of the sequence but it's okay if
you're not familiar with limits
just think it's the number that this
sequence approaches
so let's get back to the original
question what is .99 repeating equals
one
even claiming all it's saying is that
this sequence 0.9 0.99 0.999 and so on
is approaching a real number and that
number is 1. well
isn't that obvious you already knew that
here's a plot of the first few terms of
the sequence
you can see that it's definitely going
to one pretty quickly
so at this point do i even really need
to give a proof
now that you understand what this
statement is actually claiming
it doesn't seem so mystical anymore does
it what it's actually claiming is just
pretty mundane but i did say that i will
give
a real proof so here it is all we have
to show is that that sequence of
0.9999 approximations is getting closer
and closer to 1.
okay so let's just look at the
difference x n minus 1 and absolute
value
plug in the expression for xn and you
see that
that difference is 10 to the minus n or
1 over 10 to the n if you prefer
i think a lot of people would be
comfortable stopping there and saying
okay yeah i see that this goes to zero
but if you really want to finish the
argument and give the formal definition
then okay give me some tolerance epsilon
bigger than 0
then i say well for any n that's bigger
than 1 over epsilon
we see that that difference is 10 to the
minus n
which is less than 1 over n which is
less than epsilon and that's how you
would formally show that
the sequence approaches one but of
course you already knew that
so i hope that really clears things up
for you so you don't have that
murky feeling in your stomach when you
see one of those algebraic proofs and
still don't really feel satisfied with
the conclusion all the real hard work is
just in understanding the definition
and once you understand that i think it
clears right up and i do want to address
one last thing i know that a lot of
videos phrase this
as a choice what should we choose .99
repeating to be
and that is completely fair you can take
the symbols and define them to mean
whatever you want
but notice that this whole process of
defining a repeating decimal
didn't really depend on using 0.99 the
real choice here that mathematicians
made
was not that .99 repeating equals one
the actual thing that mathematicians
decided on was
what does it mean to add up an infinite
number of things
so in that sense we didn't choose the
value of 0.99 repeating to be 1.
we chose the definition of an infinite
sum and then from that we were able to
derive
the value of 0.99 repeating and the last
thing that i want to talk about
is all those other videos now if you
just looked at the title of this video
you might think i'm trying
to start some kind of flame war which
i'm definitely not i think that
each of those videos is worth watching
and you can learn
something from each and every one of
them i just felt like none of those
videos really
fully removed the source of confusion so
that's the real reason that i wanted to
make this video just to clear things up
for you the viewer
i do want to give a special shout out to
the mathematical association of america
their video was the only one that i
found that didn't assume that .99
repeating
exists and i stole one of the examples
in this video from theirs
hey everyone that's all i've got on this
topic so thank you for watching
if you liked the video please consider
subscribing sharing with your friends
and as always slap that like button an
odd number of times
see you next time